I recently had my vitamin D level tested. It is 120 on my blood test, which is high.
Is there any concern about this level? I had cancer many years ago. This person's husband has cancer.
I was previously taken four of the ADK complete, reduced it to one a few weeks ago because we were on vacation in Aruba.
Oh, you know, I made a mistake. You know, if you guys go to Aruba, you have to bring me with, you know, it's just for safety reasons. So I forgot to tell you that that sounds like a good idea.
Sorry. Okay. 4 ADK avail is 20,000. I use deep. So it's 5,000. I use vitamin D at each ADK. I typically recommend you take it one.
So, but that being said, having a vitamin D level of 120, you know, that's high by medical standards. I think it turns in the lab. Some labs 30 to 80 is within normal wage. Some labs.
It's 30 to 100. I want, you know, anybody. I think it's better for anybody with cancer to have a vitamin D level over 80.
And I don't concerned about the high point at that level, unless it's over 200, maybe over 150.
Somebody who doesn't have cancer vitamin D levels of 120 is that too high.
Really, but I don't think you need to be taking 4 ADKs or 20,000 I use. I think going down to one a day is really probably the right thing to do.
I'd be at 5,000 a day, especially going into the summer.
That's what I would do.